Welcome to episode 99 of What's Up Prof.
Walter, can you believe that?
Episode 99.
That means that the next one will be
episode 100.
It will be a jubilee.
A jubilee. Well, I hope then we can go
home.
I hope so, too.
Well, today we've got an interesting
subject, the covenants of God. Yes.
And there's a lot of confusion on this,
so we'll need the Holy Spirit's
enlightenment.
Our heavenly Father, thank you again for
blessing us and bringing us thus far.
Lord, every all the glory to you.
Nothing we could have done without you,
and we ask that you again bless this
discussion
and all the viewers and listeners in
Jesus' name. Amen.
Amen.
Well, Martin, why are we talking about
the covenants? Because this is an
essential feature for the last days.
Mhm.
Because there is a people
that is a covenant people.
Mhm. Even in the times that we are
living in.
And
this is the new covenant.
Now, we need to understand this issue
because there's so much confusion.
And sometimes the nuances are so close.
Yeah.
That just a slight
movement
or just a slightly different emphasis
can change the entire theology. True.
If we think of a verse, for example,
"Verily, verily, I say to you,
today you will be with me in heaven."
Mhm.
Or "Verily, verily, I say to you today,
you will be with me in heaven." Yeah.
There's a vast difference between the
two theologies, and they're exactly the
same wording.
So, we need to be very careful how we
weigh these things.
And that
Yeah. Yeah, and where the emphasis is
being put. And what the importance is
for the times that we are living in.
Because one of the things that you will
hear constantly about people that claim
that the commandments of God are binding
is legalism. Yes. Because we're under a
new covenant.
Yes. And then from the other side you
will hear liberalism. Mhm.
And where is the balance? And we have to
find the answer in the covenants. So, I
think it is appropriate that we end
basically with this one at number 99
because
I hope that very soon we will see the
coming of the Lord. I hope so, too.
So, let's ask a few questions. What is
the purpose of a covenant?
What is the difference between a
biblical covenant and a normal covenant?
For how long is a covenant valid?
And what is the compulsory requirement
on the human side of such a covenant if
it is made with God, for example?
And what is God's covenant obligation?
What's his obligation? So, what's the
purpose of the of a covenant?
Well, the biblical one is also for the
benefit of man. Yes, and it's a an
agreement, right?
Yeah.
And
you need two parties for a covenant to
go into effect.
You don't make a covenant with yourself,
hey? You can make a resolution, but you
don't make a covenant.
Yes. Yes.
And what's the difference between a
biblical covenant and a normal covenant?
Well,
basically, they have to be ratified by
law. Yeah.
So, the one that is biblical is you are
making it with the highest sovereign in
the universe
or the highest sovereign in the universe
is making it with you. Yes.
Let's rather put it that way. The
biblical ones is always God initiating
it. Always God initiating it.
And a normal covenant
normally comes out of necessity
somewhere.
And how long is a covenant valid? Until
it is disannulled or somebody doesn't
keep to the covenant, right? Correct.
Then it's no longer valid.
And what is the compulsory requirement
on the human side?
Therefore, to keep your side of the
bargain.
And what is God's covenant obligation?
Keep his side of the bargain.
It's a simple thing, right?
So, this is not rocket science. It's a
simple judicial process.
Yeah.
So, we have a question. Why did God
enter into the covenants with humans?
Well, here's a quote from that I might
know him, and it says, "Through
transgression,
man lost his holy innocence and
mortgaged himself to Satan.
Christ, the only begotten Son of God,
pledged himself for the redemption of
man
and paid the price of his ransom on the
cross of Calvary.
He left the worlds unfallen, the society
of holy angels in the universe of
heaven,
for he could not be satisfied while
humanity was alienated from him.
The heavenly merchant man lays aside his
royal robe and crown. Though the prince
and commander of all heaven, he takes
upon him the garb of humanity
and comes to a world that is marred and
seared with the curse
to seek for the one lost pearl, to seek
for man fallen through disobedience.
It's interesting in this parable of the
lost pearl, there is this double
application.
Mhm.
The pearl of great price is obviously
Christ, and we have to find it, right?
But Christ also came to seek for the
lost pearls
of his kingdom. So, it has this double
application.
But the initiator who comes is God. He
wants to restore that relationship that
he had with Adam and Eve before the
fall.
It's also important to note that God
created humanity
with a particular nature. Mhm.
And it was not a fallen nature. Yeah.
And it was a nature in the image of God,
in harmony with God.
So, let's have a look at a few biblical
covenants. There was the covenant with
Adam.
And you read about it in Genesis 3:15,
then with Noah and his sons, with
Abraham, with Isaac, with Jacob, with
Moses, and then a new covenant.
Which you read about for the first time
in Jeremiah chapter 33.
So, let's have a look at some of these.
Adam and Eve, Genesis 3:15, "And I will
put enmity between thee and the woman,
and between thy seed and her seed. It
shall bruise thy head, and thou shalt
bruise his heel."
Referring to the seed
shall bruise the head.
Now, Paul makes it quite clear that the
seed is singular
and is a reference to Christ.
Yes.
So, there will be enmity between
Satan's church and God's church.
And it will end with the bruising of the
heel of Christ and the destruction of
Satan. That's a That's a promise.
The plan of salvation.
Sorrow filled heaven as it was realized
that man was lost.
And that world which God had created was
to be filled with mortals doomed to
misery, sickness, and death.
And there was no way of escape for the
offender. The whole family of Adam must
die.
I saw the lovely Jesus and beheld an
expression of sympathy and sorrow upon
his countenance. Soon I saw him approach
the exceeding bright light
which enshrouded the Father.
"Said my accompanying angel, he is in
close converse with his Father.
The anxiety of the angels seemed to be
intense while Jesus was communing with
the Father.
Three times he was shut in by the
glorious light about the Father and the
third time he came from the Father, his
person could be seen.
His countenance was calm, free from all
perplexity and doubt, and shone with
benevolence and loveliness
such as words cannot express.
He then made known to the angelic host
that a way of escape had been made for
lost man.
He told them that he had been pleading
with his Father and had offered to give
his life a ransom
to take the sentence of death upon
himself that through him man might find
pardon.
That through the merits of his blood and
obedience to the law of God
they could have the favor of God
and be brought into the beautiful garden
and eat of the fruit of the tree of
life.
So, this is a this is a story
of
how the plan of redemption was planned
and contrived.
Yeah, it comes forth as in compassion.
Correct.
just an arbitrary decision. It's a very
personal, compassionate
decision.
Then there was the covenant with Noah.
It's always interesting
that there seems to be a human failure
and then the covenant has to be renewed,
right?
That's true. So, the antediluvian world
had to be destroyed and a covenant was
made with Noah.
Genesis 6:18, but with thee will I
establish my covenant and thou shalt
come into the ark thou and thy sons and
thy wife and thy sons' wives with thee.
And God said, "This is the token of the
covenant."
Genesis 9:12
which I make between me and you and
every living creature that is with you
for perpetual generations.
I do set my bow
in the clouds and it shall be for a
token of a covenant between me and the
earth.
So, here God puts a physical sign as a
perpetual reminder of a covenant.
Yeah.
And that sign exists to this very day,
right?
Exactly.
So, we have to ask ourselves, what are
the similarities between the covenant
with Noah
and the covenant with Adam?
Was the covenant with Noah only
one-sided?
Well, Noah had to obey, right?
Yes, if he didn't go into the ark would
he have been saved?
No, if he didn't construct it either.
Exactly.
think he was mocked?
Uh for sure. Scientists told him that
there couldn't be a flood. It was
absolutely impossible.
Yes. It had never rained upon the earth,
the Bible says.
And here this man was predicting
something that was impossible.
So, if it had never rained, then there
was also not a rainbow.
Correct. Because there was no moisture
prism to reflect that uh
light and to break it up into its
components.
Mhm.
So, this covenant is a covenant which
says, "I won't do it this way again."
And it couldn't have been one-sided
because there was a reciprocal act on
the part of Noah. Yes.
So, let's read about Noah's covenant
obligation. After he had given the signs
of his coming, Christ said
"When you see these things come to pass,
know ye that the kingdom of God is nigh
at hand. Take ye heed, watch and pray."
God has always given men warning of
coming judgments.
Those who had faith in his message for
their time
and who acted out their faith in
obedience to his commandments escaped
the judgments that fell upon the
disobedient and unbelieving.
There's always that basis. It is. If you
remember the previous statement where
Jesus went to the Father
it would have been subject to his blood
and the obedience to the commandments.
Correct. And Adam and Eve, they were
under a covenant obligation
to keep the decrees of God and to listen
and not to partake of that particular
tree of the knowledge of good and evil
and they broke the covenant.
Yeah. That didn't make them legalist to
keep that commandment.
No, of course not.
The word came to Noah, "Come thou and
all thy house into the ark, for thee
have I seen righteous before me." Noah
obeyed
and was saved. The message came to Lot,
"Up, get you out of this place, for the
Lord will destroy the city."
Lot placed himself under the
guardianship of the heavenly messengers
and was saved.
Now, was Lot perfect, Morton? No.
He was pretty defective, right?
Yes, he And even after he was saved
he managed to get hold of a bottle store
in Zoar and took uh
his his little drinks to a cave
and the result is a nightmare, right?
Exactly.
But what was his saving grace?
Put his trust in God. He believed. Yes.
And he went out.
And he didn't look back. No.
So, Christ's disciples were given
warning of the destruction of Jerusalem.
Those who watched for the signs of the
coming ruin and fled from the city
escaped the destruction.
So, now we are given warning of Christ's
second coming and of the destruction to
fall upon the world and those who heed
the warning
will be saved.
So, there is a warning
there is a commitment
Yes. there is a active obedience and
there is a result. That's it.
That's the covenant, basically, right?
That's how it works.
Now, since we are living in these days
where the greatest of them all, the
greatest destruction of all time
will come to pass
and therefore it is essential
that we
believe
like Abraham believed, like Noah
believed, like the disciples believe
and obey. Then that faith also has to go
into practice.
Correct.
You know, there's that song that hymn
that we sing
"Trust and obey, for there's no other
way to be happy in Jesus but to trust
and obey."
If you go through the Bible, then you
read it constantly that the Holy Spirit
was given to them that
obey him.
So, you cannot divorce the obedience
from this activity.
But it's important that we understand
the little nuances.
Yes. And we'll get to that.
So, let's have a look at what happened
with Abraham.
Genesis 12:1-3, "Now the Lord had said
unto Abraham
get thee out of thy country and from thy
kindred and from thy father's house unto
a land which I will show thee.
And I will make thee a great nation and
I will bless thee and make thy name
great and thou shalt be a blessing.
And I will bless them that bless thee
and curse him that curses thee and in
thee shall all the families of the earth
be blessed."
That's quite a tall order, right?
Separate yourself from your country.
Is that important?
Yes.
Okay. Why?
Because the norms and standards of a
country might be totally different to
the norms and standards that God has in
mind for you, right?
From your kindred?
From your father's house? From your
broader family? From your immediate
family?
And get out to a land that I will show
you.
That's tall order.
And then the promise in Genesis 17:7-10,
"And I will establish
my covenant between me and thee and thy
seed after thee the in their generations
for an everlasting covenant to be a God
unto thee and to thy seed after thee.
This is my covenant
which you shall keep between me and you
and thy seed after thee. Every man child
amongst you shall be circumcised."
So, this was a covenant of circumcision.
Mhm.
Whose covenant was it?
God's covenant. It's very important,
right?
You have to realize that when you read
this.
Abraham didn't do this
covenant with God. Okay. It's God's
covenant. So, let's ask another
question. Does God make mistakes? No.
Does he sometimes
uh make a temporary mistake and has to
correct it? No.
So, does God have foreknowledge? Yes.
All right, so he made a covenant, so it
must have been a pretty good covenant,
right?
Exactly. Okay, and it was called the s-
covenant of circumcision.
Now, Martin, does that mean that if you
circumcise
your male offspring,
then that is enough?
No, or does it mean something deeper
than that?
You see,
a lot of people probably think this
replaced something in the previous
covenants.
But it's just a continuation, a renewal
like you said. And like what you've just
said is no, it
there's always something deeper in the
covenant than just the physical that you
have to do. Correct. And it it didn't
only include Abraham,
it included his offspring.
Mhm. Okay.
Therefore, it's important that the
symbol was that of circumcision, which
is a symbol of the circumcision of the
heart,
Yes. which is a symbol of that which you
believe and cherish as a moral value
which you want to transfer to your
children.
Exactly. So, that's the package. So, are
the
the girls excluded now? No.
No, they're part of it because even
girls
are in the genetic system of Abraham.
Yes, and they are under
their husbands.
Correct. Now, who determines
in amongst the two sexes whether the
offspring is going to be male or female?
Is it the the mother or the or the
father? The father.
Yes, the father because the father is
the only one that has a Y chromosome or
an X chromosome to contribute, right?
Mhm.
So,
the the ladies are incorporated in this
covenant.
Yeah,
there can't be any offspring without the
ladies.
Correct. So, they won't be in a covenant
with the with the race.
That's a very interesting point, by the
way,
because who was first, Adam or Eve?
Adam.
Adam was first, right?
Mhm.
So,
did Adam have all the genetic capacity
to accommodate an Eve? Yes.
He had an X chromosome and he had a Y
chromosome, right?
Yes.
All right. Now, if Adam had not been
first, but Eve had been first, would she
had have had all the genetic
capabilities in order to be able to
produce an Adam? No. No,
because she doesn't have a Y chromosome.
So, Adam had to be first. The Bible is
right again, and science, unfortunately,
is wrong.
So, how did the covenant change when
Abraham's name was changed to Abraham?
And what are the similarities and
differences between the previous
covenants made with Adam and Noah?
And was the sacrifice of Isaac also part
of the covenant?
Those are interesting questions, Martin.
So, how did it change?
Well, Abraham's
name was changed to Abraham, which means
father of nations.
Yes.
So, in other words, the covenant just
basically included humanity,
right?
Yeah.
Well, I think it probably from the start
God had that in mind.
Correct. And he just opened up the
covenant explanation a little bit more
for Abraham through doing this.
But the means by which it was to be
propagated, namely his offspring,
uh was somewhat hampered by the
barrenness of his wife. Mhm, but that's
it was a test.
That was a test, and God specifically
waited until she was off the
childbearing, so that it would have to
be a miracle
Exactly. of his doing.
In case humanity thinks that it is their
doing. So, there's a lot hidden in this
covenant, right?
And what are the similarities
between the previous covenants made with
Adam and Noah? Well, obviously Noah
was the father of the post-flood world.
So, if a covenant made was made with
Noah,
then
it included the whole of humanity.
As as did the one with Adam. Correct.
But Noah didn't have the covenant of
circumcision.
So, Martin, what is happening here is
that you have a shift from a physical
reality Mhm.
to a spiritual reality, namely
the heart,
because circumcision was a symbol of the
circumcision of the heart.
Mhm.
So, now we're moving from the reality of
a a physical manifestation
that literally Noah is the father of the
post-flood
human race
to a covenant with those that make a
decision in their hearts.
Mhm.
Big difference, right?
Yes. And actually, um you can correct me
if I'm wrong, but
that was all
in a way, that was also what God meant
with the first covenant. Correct.
It should have already been with the
heart. It should have been, but it
wasn't.
No. Right? Another similarity is that
God initiated it again.
Correct.
Now, what about the sacrifice of Isaac?
Was it part of the covenant?
If I had to answer that,
I would say no, it was not part of the
covenant, but it was a test
Mhm.
as to the sincerity
of Abraham
in accepting and believing the covenant.
Yes, that's exactly like his test was
with
his barren wife. Correct. Because it was
supposed to be through Isaac, and now he
had to sacrifice Isaac.
That must have created some cognitive
dissonance, right?
But it shows you again
the other part, that other nuance, the
faith part that has to come out in a
covenant. Now, we're dealing with the
issue of faith.
So, Abraham is a witness to the
universe. Heavenly beings were witnesses
of the scene as the faith of Abraham and
the submission of Isaac were tested.
The trial was far more severe
than that which had had been brought
upon Adam.
Compliance with the prohibition laid
upon our first parents involved no
suffering,
but the command to Abraham demanded the
most agonizing sacrifice. All heaven
beheld with wonder and admiration of
Abraham's unfaltering obedience.
All heaven applauded his fidelity.
Satan's accusations were shown to be
false.
God declared to his servants, "Now I
know that thou fearest God,
notwithstanding Satan's charges,
seeing thou hast not withheld thine thy
son, thine only son from me."
God's covenant confirmed to Abraham by
an oath before the intelligences of the
other world testified that obedience
will be rewarded.
Again, you have the element of
obedience.
Mhm.
But he had to rationalize it.
He had to say to himself, "Now, God
promised my offspring through this
child.
Now, God requires the sacrifice of this
Therefore, because I believe
that God is faithful and will not lie to
me,
I must expect some miracle, and God will
resurrect him." Yeah.
And then he acted upon it.
And his faith was accredited to him for
righteousness. You know what? I think
we've got a lot of this going on in our
current day.
There's a lot of things happening in the
world, and a lot of people are confused.
If we
put our faith like Abraham in God, no
matter how dark the circumstance right
now,
he will provide for you.
Correct.
And in a sense, he was enacting the plan
of salvation.
Oh, yes.
Cuz we read in Genesis chapter 22 from
verse 5, and Abraham said unto his young
men,
"Abide you here with the ass, and I and
the lad will go yonder and worship, and
come again to you."
That tells you he believed that even
after the sacrifice, he would bring
Isaac back. Right?
And Abraham took the wood of the burnt
offering and laid it upon Isaac his son.
And he took the fire in his hand and a
knife, and they went both of them
together.
This is a symbol of Christ who carried
the cross for us.
And Isaac spoke unto Abraham his father
and said, "My father."
And he said, "Here am I, my son."
And he said, "Behold the fire and the
wood, but where is the lamb for a burnt
offering?"
And Abraham said, "My son,
God will provide himself a lamb for a
burnt offering."
So, they went both of them together.
Here was a
mini enactment of the plan of salvation.
And it's interesting that here in the
King James version,
it says, "God will provide himself Yeah.
a lamb."
Now, if you take the New King James
version, it totally destroys this verse
and says, "And Abraham said, 'My son,
God will provide for himself
a lamb.'"
No, God doesn't provide for himself a
lamb. He provides a lamb for us.
For sinners. Because how can he
provide himself if he's sinless?
It's totally ridiculous, but that's why,
you know,
sometimes you have to make sure that you
read it where it makes sense.
So, Christ personally presents himself
to Abraham. Though this covenant was
made with Adam
and renewed to Abraham, it could not be
ratified until the death of Christ.
That's why you have this beautiful
typology in there.
It had existed by the promise of God
since the first intimation of redemption
had been given.
It had been accepted by faith, yet when
ratified by Christ, it is called a new
covenant.
So, what we read here, Martin, is that
there's really no difference between the
covenants of Adam and Abraham,
but it had to be ratified by the death
of Christ. So, that enactment of the
plan of salvation
was a glimpse into the future.
And now with Christ then being
physically there,
the nuance changed a little bit. And it
became
full of substance.
That's it.
So, the law of God was the basis of the
covenant. There was obedience involved.
Which was simply an arrangement for
bringing men again into harmony with the
divine will, placing them where they
could obey God's law.
If it were not possible for human beings
under the Abrahamic covenant to keep the
commandments of God, every soul of us is
lost.
All right, how difficult was it for
Abraham to keep the commandment to take
your son, your only son, although it
wasn't his only son, but it was
his son first in preeminence.
Mhm.
Take him and sacrifice him. Is that a
difficult command to fulfill?
Definitely. Is it harder than, "Don't
eat of that tree"? Yes.
It's definitely harder, right?
a big
um
knowing consequence. Okay. So, he did
it.
So, could he keep it? Could he keep that
command of God? Yes. Well, he did it,
right?
Mhm.
How much faith did he have to have?
Full on.
Faith, lots of it.
And he must have expected that God will
keep his promise
and that he will resurrect Isaac.
Although God never said he would
resurrect him, but he said that his seed
would be through Isaac and therefore
that was the logical consequence, right?
So, the Abrahamic covenant is the
covenant of grace.
By grace are you saved. Disobedient
children? No, obedient to all his
commandments.
Abraham's unquestioning obedience was
one of the most striking instances of
faith and reliance upon God to be found
in the sacred record.
Just such faith and confidence as
Abraham had, the messengers of God need
today.
Martin, I get so many letters
and messages,
and I'm sure you do, too,
of people that
ask, "What must we do now?"
Exactly.
Uh God said so,
and now I'm being told otherwise.
"What must I do? I need to eat. I need
to save my family."
Uh we have to practice the faith of
Abraham, right?
Yes.
And realize that no matter how
horrendous it sounds,
God has promised to take care of us,
right?
Hard.
That it it's hard, but
that was promised. This will
will happen. Okay. So, let's move on to
the covenant with Moses. Because every
time we see a little nuance added,
right?
And we haven't seen a change. If you if
you look at these, because now some
people might say, "Okay, so circumcision
is a different covenant than the one
with Adam." No, it was still obedience.
It's still the same. But the heart had
been incorporated. All right, now let's
go to Moses.
And God spake unto Moses and said unto
him, "I am the Lord, and I appeared unto
Abraham, unto Isaac, and unto Jacob by
the name of God Almighty.
But by my name Jehovah was I not known
to them."
So, basically, what does that mean,
Martin?
What it means is
Abraham and Isaac and Jacob
were given this
a picture of God
as the almighty ruler of the universe.
Now, the almighty ruler of the universe
says, "This is what I want you to do."
And they did it. Yes. Okay.
Now, here he says, "I've changed this
now.
And I come to you, Moses,
with my personal name."
Uh that's something we do amongst
friends, right? If you get an official
letter from some company, they say, "Mr.
Smith, uh we have something that we want
to discuss with you, right?"
They don't say, "Hey, Marty."
That wouldn't work, right? All right, so
now here he comes
with a personal name.
"And I have also established my covenant
with them to give them the land of
Canaan, the land of their pilgrimage
wherein they were strangers.
And I've also heard the groaning of the
children of Israel whom the Egyptians
keep in bondage and have remembered my
covenant.
Wherefore say unto the children of
Israel, 'I am the Lord.'"
So, here is the name, Yahweh,
the personal
name.
"And I will bring you
out from under the burdens of the
Egyptians, and I will rid you out of
their bondage, and I will redeem you
with a stretched out arm,
and with great judgments, and I will
take you to me for a people, and I will
be to you a God, and you shall know that
I am the Lord your God which brings you
out from under the burdens of the
Egyptians, and I will bring you into the
land concerning that which I did swear
to give to Abraham, to Isaac, and to
Jacob, and I will give it to you for a
heritage, for I am
the Lord." His personal name.
So, it's the same covenant that he's
going to put into effect,
but he's come a little bit
closer. Yeah, he in a personal way.
That's it. He's he's presenting himself
in a little bit different way.
Almost actually in in the same way that
he was with Adam. Correct.
So, what are the similarities with the
previous covenant?
The conditional aspect of the Sinai
covenant is identical with the intent of
the conditional statements of the
Abrahamic covenant,
which is clearly a covenant of grace. So
say Gerhard Hasel and Michael Hasel
in this book, God's Everlasting
Covenant.
So,
with Abraham, we had the element of
grace and the heart. Now we have a
personal covenant. So, the conditions
haven't changed, just the relationship
has become closer. Yeah.
So, who gave the law to Moses?
It was Christ, right?
Christ.
In all these revelations
of the divine presence, the glory of God
was manifested through Christ.
Not alone at the Savior's advent, but
through all the ages after the fall and
the promise of redemption, God was in
Christ reconciling the world unto
himself.
Quoting 2 Corinthians 5:19. Christ was
the foundation and center of the
sacrificial system
in both the patriarchal and Jewish age.
It was the Son of God that gave to our
first parents the promise of redemption.
It was he who revealed himself to the
patriarchs. Adam, Noah, Abraham, Isaac,
Jacob, and Moses understood the gospel
in type, of course, right?
They looked for salvation through man's
substitute and surety. These holy men of
old had communion with the Savior
who was to come to our world in human
flesh, and some of them talked with
Christ and heavenly angels face to face.
We have numerous examples in the Bible.
Christ was not only the leader of the
Hebrews in the wilderness, the angel in
whom was the name of Jehovah,
and who, veiled in the pillar went
before the host.
But it was he who gave the law to Israel
amid the awful glory of Sinai.
Christ declared in the hearing of all
the people the 10 precepts of his
father's law.
It was he who gave to Moses the law
engraved upon the tables of stone.
Now we read this in the book Patriarchs
and Prophets.
And people will ask how do we know that
it was Jesus and not the Father?
Because the Bible is very clear that
Jesus was the word. Yes.
And that was spoken and if it was the
Father that spoke the Bible very
specifically says so like at the baptism
of Jesus.
That's it. But the rest all things were
created by him and for him and without
him was not anything created, right?
That is the biblical
uh precept. It's so beautiful. It just
emphasizes the divinity of Christ.
Absolutely. And that's why you find it
in those
first lines of the Gospel of John.
So law is God's specific way of life
within the covenant between himself and
humankind.
It was there from the beginning.
There was a command and it had to be
kept. Yeah.
Thus God's covenant with its law, the
two together, constitute God's means of
keeping his people in a state of
redemption.
They remain in this state not by obeying
the law through their own strength and
discipline, but rather by God's
continuing presence. This is very
important.
Power and activity of grace and mercy in
their lives enabling them to obey him.
Where does the enabling you to obey him
come from? From God.
Obedience or law is an act of faith
through which the believer confesses his
love and loyalty to God.
Genuine faith produces obedience.
Abraham obeyed my voice and kept my
charge, my commandments, and my
statutes, and my laws, says Genesis
26:5.
Paul argued correctly that keeping the
law is the fruit of a right relationship
with God rather than the means to earn
or merit the right relationship with
God. Paul's exegesis of Leviticus 18:5
is faithful to the text's original
setting.
The law was given to the covenant people
after their redemption from Egypt,
quoting Leviticus, not as a moral hurdle
to be cleared or a meritorious activity
to be performed if they wish to be
saved,
but as a description of the love
motivated lifestyle of God's redeemed
people. I don't think you can say it
better.
It's amazing. That's why God says
remember. He didn't say do this and then
I'll do something for you. He saved them
and said remember why I saved you?
Show me through your obedience. Correct.
He uses the words of Moses himself from
Leviticus 18:5 to remind the legalists
that while righteousness comes by faith,
it is a faith that issues or manifests
itself in obedience.
He says in Romans, do we thereby make
void the law through faith? God forbid.
We uphold the law.
But such obedience believers are not
able to render unaided. That's very
important, Martin.
Without the enabling grace provided by
God through the Holy Spirit. Thus it is
evidence that the way of salvation in
the Old Testament
and the way of salvation in the New
Testament are the same.
Both being salvation by grace through
faith which results in obedience.
I think this is very well put in that
book
uh by the two Hassels, father and son.
Mhm.
The father is deceased now already,
but I think it sums it up pretty well.
So when the law was placed inside the
ark of the covenant,
then it tells you that that is the heart
of the government of God, right?
Deuteronomy 10:2 and I will write on the
tables the words that were on the first
tables which thou breakest and thou
shalt put them in the ark.
Mhm.
And then there was the ceremonial law
which we read about in Deuteronomy 31:26
that Moses wrote and it says take this
book of the law
and put it in the side of the ark of the
covenant of the Lord your God that it
may be there for a witness against thee.
So that was placed on the side, the 10
commandments were placed inside.
And we were shielded from the
condemnation by the law
from this mercy seat
that is basically the throne of God.
So if we read further from Hassels'
book, it says the Sabbath is a covenant
sign
with three time dimensions.
It carries significance for the here and
now. It reflects on the past and it
reaches into the future.
It reflects back in that it was
instituted at creation and is a memorial
of God's creation of this world.
It says something significant relating
to God's activity in the present
confirming a covenant sign in the lives
of those who acknowledge God as their
Lord
that they have accepted his lordship and
redemption and that they live as they do
by his power.
Then the Sabbath reaches into the
ultimate future finding its complete
fulfillment in the plan of salvation
when total unlimited freedom and final
redemption will be experienced. The
Sabbath links creation with the new
creation quoting Genesis and Isaiah.
So it's very important that we
understand the Sabbath
because it is part of the covenant. It's
in the 10 commandments.
Yes. It's in the heart of the covenant.
And it has the signet of God. It has the
stamp of his authority. Why? Because I
am the creator and I am the one who
created heaven and earth and therefore I
initiated the seventh day Sabbath.
Yeah.
And that's so important what you just
said.
God initiated the covenant. He wrote the
10 commandments. Who can take anything
out of those commandments?
Nobody. Nobody. And if you do, then it
is arrogance of the highest order.
So Exodus 25:9
talks about the tabernacle that had to
be made according to all that I show
thee after the pattern of the tabernacle
and the pattern of all the instruments
thereof, even so shall ye make it.
So the earthly sanctuary served as a
type of the plan of salvation. And it
was a copy
of the house of God in heaven. Correct.
And here there were earthly priests that
officiated, but in the heavenly there
was a better priest that officiated.
And so also the covenant
became adjusted, let's put it that way.
Yeah.
But it remains the same covenant, but
there's an adjustment and it's very
important that we understand the
adjustment.
So let's look at the adjustment, Martin,
the new covenant.
The first time we read that God will
make a new covenant is
in the book of Jeremiah. Now it's
interesting
that here again you had a destruction.
Yes. Jeremiah warned
that Nebuchadnezzar would come and he
would destroy Jerusalem and the temple,
right?
And yet he predicts a new covenant.
Now why was it destroyed? Because they
broke the old covenant.
Yes.
Was the Sabbath pivotal in that breaking
of the covenant?
Yes.
Correct. You read about it in Ezekiel,
right?
You didn't do it.
That's why when the Jews returned, they
put so many
stringent rules into place to make sure
that nobody broke the Sabbath again and
by those stringent rules they broke the
Sabbath.
Exactly.
Now they made it a human thing and not a
relationship thing. So if you take out
the heart
and you make it a rule of the flesh,
then you end up with crucifying God all
over again, right? So what is the
nuance? Let's read it.
Behold, the days come, says the Lord,
that I will make a new covenant with the
house of Israel and with the house of
Judah. And then
it's bold here. Not according to the
covenant that I made with their fathers.
In the day that I took them by the hand
to bring them out of the land of Egypt.
Which my covenant they break.
Who broke the covenant, Martin?
Them, not God. Okay.
Although I was a husband unto them, says
the Lord.
But this shall be the covenant that I
will make with the house of Israel after
those days, says the Lord.
Yes, and he's doing it again. I will put
my law in their inward parts
and write it in their hearts and will be
their God and they shall be my people.
And they shall teach no more every man
his neighbor and every man his brother
saying, "Know the Lord."
For they shall all know me, from the
least of them unto the greatest of them,
says the Lord.
For I will forgive their iniquity and I
will remember their sin no more.
So, Martin, here's a new covenant
and it's definitely not according to the
covenant that I made with their fathers.
But I'm the Lord, I change not. So, now
what do you do? Yeah, did he make a
uh a mistake with the previous one?
Correct. Then he made the mistake by
repetition because he made it with Adam.
And he made it with Noah and he made it
with Abraham and Isaac and Jacob and
then he made it with Moses.
And now he's promising a new one. Yeah,
because he made a mistake.
He made a mistake. God is obviously very
fallible, right?
Basically, that's what modern theology
teaches. That's what you hear from all
over the world.
And it's it's simply not possible.
So, we have to be very certain and sure
as to why it is not according to the
covenant that he made with their
fathers, right? So, we have to go into
that a little bit so that we can
understand.
So, why is it called a new covenant?
Let's just hear what the Hazells have to
say about this.
We should be careful
not to superimpose modern-day meanings
upon biblical usage when it comes to
understanding the intent, purpose, and
design
of biblical language.
The term new with regard to the new
covenant in Jeremiah 31:31
is the Hebrew term hadash.
This Hebrew term means frequently to
renew or to restore
and something new which was not yet
present in the same quality or way
before.
Reflecting both senses, the new covenant
is simply renewed or restored
covenant, also now having
characteristics not present in the same
way or quality as before.
God does not speak of a new law
but a new covenant.
Right. Now, this is very important. We
must understand that God never makes a
mistake.
If there is a mistake,
it's on our side. Correct, and he never
changes. So, here he makes a renewal of
the covenant, which means the covenant
hasn't changed.
But the terms in which it is applied
Mhm.
they are being changed.
Yes. Let's have a look at it in a little
bit more detail.
Let's jump to the book of Hebrews. If
you want a more
complete analysis, uh there's the series
on substance and shadow. You can look at
chapter 8 where we speak about it.
Here's a little extract of Hebrews
chapter 8 from verse 6.
But now has he obtained a more excellent
ministry.
By how much also is he the mediator of a
better covenant, which was established
upon better promises.
So, the covenant now is better.
And it is established on better
promises. So, were the old ones bad? No.
No, they fulfilled the purpose within
the capacity that was given them. Yeah.
But they couldn't exceed that capacity.
Because they were merely typological.
They were showing forward. Correct. So,
let's look at verse 7. For if that first
covenant had been faultless, then should
no place have been sought for the
second.
Question.
So, was it faulty?
No. No, it wasn't faulty, but he says it
was faulty. Now, only in the application
was it faulty because it had certain
limitations. Yes. Not of God's causing.
No. That's very important. So, it's not
God's side that had the faulty part in
it.
Correct. So, the covenant was perfect
for what it was designed to do.
But it was faulty
because of the human element.
Yes.
So, for finding fault with them
did he find fault with the covenant? No.
He found fault with them that was
supposed to keep the covenant.
He says, "Behold, the days come," says
the Lord, "when I
will make a new covenant with the house
of Israel and with the house of Judah."
So, who initiates this new way? God
again.
God. Does he disannul everything and say
sorry that it was all wrong? Obviously
not, right?
No. And the thing is
a lot of people want to say now they
couldn't keep
the covenant, that's why he changed it
now. Correct.
But that can't be true. Because why
would God give something if he know you
can't do it? And in any case, Abraham is
the father of those that believe because
he kept it according to the Bible.
Exactly. All right, so let's just break
this down again. The old covenant was a
two-way covenant to which all the people
agreed.
We read about it in Exodus chapter 19.
Now, therefore, if you will obey my
voice indeed and keep my covenant, this
is God speaking,
then you shall be a peculiar treasure
unto me above all people, for all the
earth is mine.
And you shall be unto me a kingdom of
priests and a holy nation. These are the
words which thou shalt speak unto the
children of Israel.
And Moses came and called for the elders
of the people and laid before their
faces all these words which the Lord
commanded him.
And then verse 8. And all the people
answered together and said, "All that
the Lord has spoken, we will do."
And Moses returned the words of the
people unto the Lord. So, here was a
reciprocal.
Here was a statement by the other party
of the covenant saying,
"We'll do it." Every single thing, all
of it.
They did it very well, right?
Like
a few minutes later
they were making a calf. Yeah, the Lord
went back up to tell the Lord
while he was doing that, they were
they were making a golden calf and
breaking the covenant. So, where did the
fault lie?
Not with the covenant.
The fault wasn't with the covenant, the
fault was with them.
So,
it needed a new covenant.
And we will find out that even the new
covenant is the same as the old
covenant, but let's let's Exactly. Let's
just say it out now. Okay.
So, let's go to verse 9 in Hebrews.
Not according to the covenant that I
made with their fathers. That's what he
said, right?
In the day when I took them out of the
hand to lead them out of the land of
Egypt, because they continued not in my
covenant. They couldn't keep it.
They couldn't keep their side of the
bargain.
And I regarded them not, says the Lord.
And they couldn't keep it because it was
too stringent from God's side.
No, it's because of their fallen flesh
that they struggled with it.
And their lack of faith. Correct.
So, our question now is how's it
different?
Well, it's not based on what we promise,
but on what he promises. So, let's read
it from verse 10.
For this is the covenant that I will
make with the house of Israel after
those days. He's quoting from Jeremiah.
I
You see, that's very important. I will
put my laws into their minds and write
them in their hearts.
And I will be to them a God and they
shall be to me a people.
This is the covenant that I will make
with them after those days, says the
Lord. I will put my laws into their
hearts and into their minds will I write
them.
So, now you have this personal God
coming and saying, "I see the weakness
of human flesh.
And you can promise as much as you like,
but I can see that you
are just not
capable.
Therefore,
I will do it in you."
Now, who is doing it?
Jesus. All right.
Through the Holy Spirit. All right. Has
the covenant changed? No. No, the
covenant is still the same. Only the one
who enacts it in humanity is is now
taking this particular way. So, now
previously we you had the the covenant
hasn't changed. They were actually in
any case supposed to have their faith in
Jesus towards which the covenant were
showing.
Now, God is even initiating that part
also. Correct. Now, this is very
important because we are coming towards
the close of this world's history.
And we are told very pertinently that
only those who are of the faith of
Abraham
will make it, right? So, we need to
understand this.
So, if we look at the old and the new
covenant, the old covenant was based on
good promises.
But the new covenant is based on better
promises.
Not because God made a mistake, but
because it had fulfilled its role within
the time frame when it was initiated.
Yes, because
the previous one, the good one, was
showing up until Christ.
Correct. After he fulfilled
that part of the covenant, now the new
covenant is showing to
him coming again.
All right, let's look at it. You have
the the old covenant was done with an
earthly church
and a nation, a literal nation under
God, right?
It involved deliverance from Egypt.
It involved an earthly Canaan that they
went to. It involved an earthly
sanctuary with earthly priests. It
involved an earthly Jerusalem.
And it was a
covenant of mortality because all of
these priests were mortal and had to die
and had to be replaced, right?
So, the better covenant is with the
heavenly church. Now, this is very
important.
In other words, those who are in Christ
are Abraham's seed and heirs according
to the promise.
Yes.
All right, so it's a heavenly church
and it's deliverance from sin.
It's
involves a heavenly Canaan, no longer an
earthly Canaan. How many people want an
earthly Canaan, Martin?
Most. The entire system is based on an
earthly Canaan. We need to save the
planet, Martin, because this is going to
be the only Canaan that we'll ever know.
We're better get it right now and make
laws concerning climate change and we
better listen to what the Pope has to
say on the issue, right?
It involves a heavenly sanctuary, a
heavenly Jerusalem, a heavenly priest,
and it's based on immortality because
that priest never dies.
He's the author of life. So, is the is
the new covenant better than the old?
Yes, in that form. Because it is the
substance of a promise. That's it. You
had the promise and the substance is
still there's still Jesus Christ. That
brings us to the times that we are
living in.
We just had a
series where we looked at the events
that take place at the coming of Christ
and what will happen, right? And there
were those that were redeemed and those
that were not redeemed.
We need to understand how this works.
So, we read in the book Last Day Events,
"The Lord in his great mercy sent a most
precious message to his people through
Elders Waggoner and Jones.
This message was to bring more
prominently before the world the
uplifted savior,
the sacrifice for the sins of the whole
world. It presented justification
through faith in the surety.
It invited people to receive the
righteousness of Christ, which is made
manifest in obedience to all the
commandments of God."
This is brilliantly put.
So, the message of righteousness by
faith is an integral part. No, it is the
substance
of the third angel's message.
Now, the third angel's message is, "Do
not receive the mark of the beast."
Yes.
In other words, don't listen to papal
authority. Listen to God's authority.
And since the authority is ensconced in
the fourth commandment as to who has
jurisdiction over heaven and earth,
the Sabbath Sunday issue becomes a very
important point, right?
How is it
justification through faith?
This is very important.
You see, the obedience
that the people showed
was always an obedience enabled through
Christ
appropriated through faith.
So, let's look at this.
What is justification by faith?
It is the work of God in laying the
glory of man in the dust.
I don't think many people will be happy
with that, right?
That's so beautifully put. We're not as
smart as we think we are. Correct.
It is the work of God in laying the
glory of man in the dust, in doing for
man
that which is is not in the power to do
for himself.
When men see their own nothingness, they
are prepared to be clothed with the
righteousness of Christ. When they begin
to praise and exalt God all the day
long, then by beholding they are
becoming changed into the same image.
What is regeneration?
It is revealing to man what is his own
real nature, that in himself he is
worthless.
That's not a popular message.
These lessons you have never learned.
Oh, that you could realize the value of
the human soul. Sounds like a
contradiction in terms. You're
worthless,
but the value is like a pearl of great
price.
Yeah, because what's what's the message
from the world? Believe in yourself.
Correct. Follow your heart.
That's what the world says, right?
That's what the world says. So, how do
you reconcile these? Actually,
where lies the worth in humanity? The
worth in humanity lies in how they were
created originally.
In the image of God.
That's They've lost the luster. They've
lost the robe of light.
They have become subject to death.
And if they are not redeemed,
they will be obliterated forever, right?
So, the value is that they can be
restored to the original. Who does that?
Christ. All right, but man says, "I want
to do it."
Yes.
I want to do it.
So, this is not going to work. This is
salvation by faith versus salvation by
works, right?
That's it. Now, let's unpack that.
The thought that the righteousness of
Christ is imputed to us, not because of
any merit on our part,
but as a free gift from God is a
precious thought.
Now, listen carefully. The enemy of God
and man is not willing that this truth
should be clearly presented.
For he knows that if the people receive
it fully,
his power will be broken.
Martin, who can break the power of
Satan? Only Christ.
Only Christ can.
If he can control minds so that doubt
and unbelief and darkness shall compose
the experience of those who claim to be
the children of God,
he can overcome them with temptations.
That simple faith that takes God at his
word
should be encouraged.
God's people must have that faith which
will lay hold of divine power.
For by grace you are saved through
faith, and that not of yourselves, it is
a gift of God,
quoting Ephesians 2:8.
Those who believe that God for Christ's
sake has forgiven their sins should not,
through temptation, fail to press on to
fight the good fight of faith.
Their faith should grow stronger until
their Christian life, as well as their
words, shall declare the blood of Jesus
Christ cleanses us from all sins.
So, who cleanses? Jesus. And this is so
important for our time because doubt and
unbelief and darkness shall compose
overtake you. We are living in those
days. So, this is so important to show
you again where does
where does your faith even come from?
Martin.
Did Abraham believe the promises of God?
Yes. He went and sacrificed
Isaac.
Well, he didn't actually sacrifice it
because it wasn't required, but it was
in his heart to do it, right?
It was already he he sacrificed him in
his mind and faith. We need that faith
in the time that we are living in,
right? So, let's qualify.
Here's another quote. "The work of
overcoming is in our hands.
But the new covenant says, "I will write
it on your hearts." He will do it.
But we are not to overcome in our own
name or strength, and there lies the
crux of the matter.
That's why it is righteousness by faith.
For of ourselves, we cannot keep the
commandments of God. Martin, this is
that slight nuance.
The shift in emphasis
where the crux of the matter lies.
I cannot keep the commandments of God.
Now, the legalist will shout and say,
"You have capitulated."
No.
It says clearly, "I cannot of myself
keep the commandments of God."
The spirit of God must help our
infirmities.
Christ has become our sacrifice and
surety. He has become sin for us that we
might become the righteousness of God in
him.
Through faith in his name, he imputes
unto us his righteousness.
And it becomes a living principle in our
life. Christ imputes to us his sinless
character
and presents us to the Father in his own
purity.
So, my perfection is a perfection
in Christ.
Yes, like we've read also before, you
have to put your faith in Christ. He
initiates actually that faith also, and
then the outflow because of that will be
obedience to the command. Aha.
So, it is not I who can boast that I
have become obedient.
The only boast I have is that Christ
within me
has compelled me to obedience, not
because he forces or coerces me,
but because I have willingly submitted
myself to his will. Correct?
That's When Joseph was confronted by
Potiphar's wife,
his words were, "I cannot commit this
great sin against God."
So, in his own flesh,
it didn't succeed, but by the power of
God in him, he managed to escape. But
even there, he lost his cloak.
It was close.
All right. So, Christ attaches a weight
of importance to the obedience of his
children to the commandments of God.
That is clear in the Bible.
They to have are to have an intelligent
knowledge of them and bring them into
their daily life.
Man cannot keep the commandments of God
only as he is in Christ and Christ in
him. So, the only way I can keep them
is if Christ
works
that within me.
This is a nuance difference. It's not a
question of, "Oh, so you say you can't
keep them."
Actually, yes, I'm saying I can't keep
them. But if Christ is working in me, I
can. No, I must keep
Agreed. You must, because if your faith
is in him, you can do no other. Correct.
How do I appropriate that power? Through
faith. That's it. Through faith.
So, let's read it again. Man cannot keep
the commandments of God only as he is in
Christ and Christ in him.
Will you be able to do that, right?
And it is not possible for him to be in
Christ having a light on his
commandments while disregarding the
least of them.
By steadfast, willing obedience to his
word, they evidence their love for the
scent of God.
So,
the action
from the outside
is exactly the same.
Yes. To a legalist, it looks perfect
when the Pharisees keep the
commandments,
but it's not applied to the heart. It's
not written in the heart. It is an
outward action that is to gratify and
satisfy the flesh.
And that's where the problem came in
with the Israelites.
And that was the problem with the old
covenant.
They were keeping it as a
as a tradition. Correct.
Not as a faith substance. So, by
steadfast, willing obedience to his
word, they evidence their love for the
scent of God.
Not to keep the commandments of God is
not to love him.
None will keep the law of God unless
they love him, who is the only begotten
of the Father. And nonetheless, surely
if they love him, they will express that
love by obedience to him. All who love
Christ
will be loved by of the Father, and he
will manifest himself to them in all
their emergencies and perplexities.
They will have a helper in Jesus Christ.
This is the new covenant.
And just as Adam and Eve had a test, and
just as Abraham had a test, and just as
the children of Israel had a test, so
God's people at the end of time will
have a test, too.
Now, we know what those tests are. It
started off with a test on appetite.
And we repeat that test very clearly in
the book of Daniel, which is a type of
the end. So, appetite will be a test.
Then, total obedience to all God's
requirements will be a test, culminating
in the test of authority. That's the
mark of the beast. Let's go Let's work
our way towards that.
So, God will test all, even as he tested
Adam and Eve, to see whether they will
be obedient.
Our loyalty or disloyalty will decide
our destiny.
Since the fall of Adam, men in every age
have excused themselves for sinning,
charging God with their sins, saying
that they could not keep his
commandments.
This is the insinuation Satan cast at
God in heaven.
But the plea, "I cannot keep the
commandments," need never be presented
to God, for before him stands the
Savior.
The marks of the crucifixion upon his
body, a living witness that the law can
be kept.
It is not that man cannot keep the law,
but that they will not.
Rebellion.
it. So, the fruit of the spirit is
obedience. That's it, because all have
the capacity to have faith that Christ
can work in you and help you keep the
commandments.
Correct.
But Martin, you can never get to the
point where you boast and say, "Aha, I
have achieved." Because then you are
sure to have fallen.
There's a work that every one of us must
do if we would be saved in the eternal
world.
But while we must on our part do what
God has given us to do, we must realize
that having done all,
we should come far short of salvation.
Did not the Lord on his part do that
which finite sinful man cannot do for
himself?
You see the subtle
difference in thinking.
The path of presumption lies very close
to the path of faith. It's just a slight
mind shift.
Rome says it is an anathema
to believe in justification by faith
alone,
because it say they say it excludes
obedience,
which is so important.
Protestants say it is an anathema
to believe that it's not by faith alone,
because obedience can always only be the
result and not the means to salvation.
It's a subtle difference, but they've
been killing each other
for millennia as a consequence.
And unfortunately, on the Protestant
side, it's drifted on to the other part
where now the commandments Oh, it can't
be kept anymore. Correct. So, they've
done away with them.
The religious life is wholly dependent
upon the blending of both human and
divine forces.
Man is to work out his own salvation,
but he cannot do this without divine
aid. That is the bottom line.
So, Martin, when you are sealed one day,
and there is no more mediator,
the fact that you are sealed is an act
of divine aid.
That's it. It doesn't mean you are doing
anything or you have are capable of
doing anything. It's still Christ.
Correct. It means simply that you have
submitted yourself
to such an extent
that you can be protected, even if it
takes the entire angelic host.
And although Christ has paid an infinite
price to save the souls of men from
everlasting ruin, he will not do that
part of the work which was left for man
to perform.
We are to live by faith.
We are not to be controlled by impulse
and feeling, but by the principles of
God's law, and they must govern our
lives.
While we look to Jesus as the source of
all power, we shall not fail to receive
help in every time of need. For it is
God which worketh in you both to will
and to do his good pleasure.
So, it's just a nuance difference. I am
relying on Christ
to fulfill that which I in my own
strength will never be capable of.
Do you know, Martin, the Bible calls
this the mystery of salvation?
Colossians 1:26, the mystery which has
been hidden from ages and from
generations, but now has been revealed
to his saints.
Those who are of
the faith of Abraham.
To them God willed to make known what
are the riches of the glory of his
majesty amongst the Gentiles, and here's
the crux of the matter, which is Christ
in you, the hope of glory.
There lies the power.
Him we preach, warning every man and
teaching every man in all wisdom that we
may present every man perfect in
Christ Jesus.
So, that brings us then to the third
angel's message, contrasting the mark of
the beast and the seal of God.
We're heading for the final events. We
need to have a right
relationship and a right faith.
The third angel's message in verity.
Several have written to me inquiring if
the message of justification by faith is
the third angel's message.
And I have answered it is the third
angel's message in verity. What does
that mean?
Completeness, absolute.
It's the substance.
So, do not accept the mark of the beast
is righteousness by faith? Yes.
Because that obedience which you are
required to render
is the perfect sign of either your
submission
Mhm.
to Christ so that he can work within you
or your rebellion.
That's why it's righteousness by faith.
So, in Revelation 14:9 we read then the
third angel followed them saying with a
loud voice, "If anyone worships the
beast and his image and receives his
mark on his forehead or on his hand."
Very important.
Mhm.
He himself also shall drink of the wine
of the wrath of God which is poured out
full strength into the cup of his
indignation.
He shall be tormented with fire and
brimstone in the presence of the holy
angels and in the presence of the lamb.
So, it's very important that this mark
of the beast will be on the forehead or
Yeah. on the hand.
If we go to Deuteronomy and we look at
the law of God,
it says in verse 18, chapter 11,
"Therefore you shall lay up these words
of mine, which are the 10 commandments,
in your heart and
in your soul.
And bind them as a sign on your hand,
and they shall be as a frontlet between
your eyes." So, there's no or No.
there's only an and.
Mhm.
So, Martin, if we pull this through to
the Sabbath commandment, Exodus 31,
"Speak also to the children of Israel
saying, Surely my Sabbaths you shall
keep.
For it is a sign,
a mark,
between me and you throughout your
generations that you may know that I am
the Lord who sanctifies you."
So, here we have two clashing
ideologies.
Mhm.
One that is satisfied if you do as
you're told. Yeah. It's on your hand. Or
you might even be convinced that it's
right to be in rebellion towards God,
then it's in your forehead.
But God wants it
both ways. He wants your obedience to be
willing obedience because you are
convinced
and because you are obedient.
Your obedience is actually a consequence
of your convinced. All right, so it's
righteousness by faith. That's what it
is.
So, you know, here's an interesting
verse in the book of Esther,
chapter 8, verse 2.
So, the king
took off his signet ring,
which he had taken from Haman, and gave
it to Mordecai.
And Esther appointed Mordecai over the
house of Haman.
That's a very interesting typology.
Mhm.
So, the king had given his signet ring,
his mark of authority.
Yes.
Now, if you look at that word signet, do
you see the word sign in it? Yes. The
first
so you have signet and there is a sign.
So, it is the sign of his authority. So,
the ring was there
and you put your seal on whatever it is
that you did it.
That signet ring was given to Haman. The
king had taken his signet ring off and
given the authority
to an earthly potentate and said, "Here,
you have full authority." So, he's a
type of the king of heaven, God the
Father, and an earthly king
that gets this authority. But in this
case, the king is a is a symbol of
another power that is giving an earthly
power authority.
Mhm.
And he must use that authority because
he wanted to use that authority to to
destroy God's people.
Yeah.
There's another earthly king
who has a signet ring
by the authority of the dragon who gives
him his seat and great authority, and he
wants to use that signet, that sign, to
exert his authority over God's people.
What will happen to him?
The tables will be turned and Haman will
hang on that gallow, and the king took
the ring that he took from Haman and he
gave it to Mordecai.
And Esther, who is a type of the church,
put him over the house.
So, righteousness,
the real sign, the real signet, will be
the victor.
Mhm.
The reason why you keep it is very
important. Do you keep it out of fear or
the hand?
Or do you keep it out of love
and the hand?
Revelation 14:12, "Here is the patience
of the saints. Here are those who keep
the commandments of God and the faith of
Jesus."
If it's not Christ working within you,
keeping the commandments of God is
useless. The Pharisees tried that. It
was a failure.
So, here's a quote from Testimonies to
Ministers, "The angels of God do his
bidding, holding back the winds of
earth,
that the wind should not blow on the
earth, nor on the sea, nor on any tree
until the servants of God should be
sealed in their foreheads.
The mighty angel is seen ascending from
the east or sun rising. This mightiest
of angels has in his hand the seal of
the living God
or of him who alone can give life, who
can inscribe upon the foreheads the mark
or inscription
to whom shall be granted immortality,
eternal life. It is the voice of this
highest angel
that had authority to command the four
angels to keep in check the four winds
until the work was performed and until
he should give the summons to let them
loose. We are living in that time.
The winds are beginning to blow. Wow.
And when those angels let loose,
it's very important that you be sealed.
Where?
In Yeah. your forehead. That is
in your frontal lobe, in your
decision-making.
And righteousness by faith is laying
man's glory in the dust. In other words,
submitting
to the power of Christ to work in you
that which you are not capable of doing
for yourself.
And that is an act of faith. Exactly.
So, the core of the new covenant,
but also the core of all covenants,
has never changed. The law of God.
There's an earnest work of preparation
to be done by Seventh-day Adventists.
Now, let me just say that not only
Adventists,
but here in particularly they are
mentioned because again, like the
children of Israel, often they think
they must do it in their own strength.
And also like Israel, they are they
as an example to the world. Correct. If
they would stand firm in the trying
experience just before them, if they
remain true to God in the confusion and
temptation of the last days, they must
seek the Lord in humility of heart
for wisdom to resist the deceptions of
the enemy. Martin,
in the time that we are entering in now,
we need this humility of heart.
And we need to be on our knees
to seek
wisdom.
Because the deceptions are all around
us. The discordant notes that we hear
in the media and even from within our
own ranks
should make us think that we need wisdom
from God. Amen.
Ever are we to keep in mind the solemn
thought of the Lord's soon return and in
view of this to recognize the individual
work to be done.
Through the aid of the Holy Spirit, we
are to resist natural inclinations and
tendencies to wrong
and weed out of the life every
un-Christ-like element.
Thus, we shall prepare our hearts for
the reception of God's blessing
which will impart to us grace and bring
us into harmony with the faith of Jesus.
I would like to say to the the people,
now's the time
to go on your knees.
Now is the time to say, "Lord,
search my heart
to see if there is any wicked thing in
it.
Wash me. Purge me. Wash me with hyssop.
Cleanse the soul temple. If there's
anything that's wrong, make it right and
show me and help me to correct it."
Yes.
For this work of preparation, great
advantages have been granted to this
people in light bestowed. In messages of
warning and instructions sent through
the agency of the Spirit of God, we have
so much information.
"How should I live, Lord?" Go and read
it. That's it.
"How should I change my life to be able
to cope with what is coming upon the
world?" Go and read it.
Because of the increasing power of
Satan's temptations,
the times in which we live are full of
peril for the children of God and we
need to learn constantly of the great
teacher
that we may take every step in surety
and righteousness.
Wonderful scenes are opening before us
and at this time, a living testimony is
to be born in the lives of God's
professing people
so that the world may see that in this
age when evil reigns on every side,
there is yet a people who are laying
aside their will
and are seeking to do God's will.
People must see it. They must see, "Why
are you different?
Why are you doing what you are doing?
Don't you know that you are calling
trouble upon yourself?" Yeah.
And you say, "Well, didn't Abraham call
trouble upon himself when he took A-
Isaac up that hill?"
A people in whose hearts and lives
the law of God is written.
There are strong temptations before us,
sharp tests.
The commandment-keeping people of God
are to prepare for this time of trial
by obtaining in a deeper experience in
the things of God
and a practical knowledge of the
righteousness of Christ.
Not to unbelievers only, but to church
members, the words are spoken. Seek ye
the Lord while he may be found. Call ye
upon him while he is near.
This is the work that everybody has to
do. I cannot ask you to solve my problem
I can ask you for advice.
Yeah. But I cannot ask you to solve my
problem.
When it comes to hard choices that has
to be made,
you cannot you can like you say, ask for
advice, but
eventually, it will be you on your knees
with God. Correct.
1 John 5:3, "For this is the love of God
that we keep his commandments and his
commandments are not burdensome."
If we do not understand this,
if we say it's not possible to keep the
commandments, then we're making him a
liar. Yeah.
Because he kept them and he has promised
to enable us to keep them. That's it.
Malachi 3:6 says, "For I am the Lord, I
change not. Therefore, ye sons of Jacob
are not consumed." The covenant never
changed.
No.
The nuances Mhm. changed in accordance
to the time.
And since we are living in the time when
Christ has become the substance of all
the shadows,
there is this
added righteousness by faith element
that the devil has been warring against
from all eternity.
May God give us wisdom
to appropriate the righteousness of
Christ so that we can keep the
commandments and call a people out of
the world into the house of his grace.
Let's pray.
Heavenly Father,
thank you for the covenants.
Thank you that the new covenant is based
on better promises,
namely that you will enable us to do all
that the covenant requires
if we will humble ourselves before you,
if we will realize our own unworthiness
and our own human weakness
and appropriate that power through
faith,
then we will be like an army with
banners.
And may the Lord's law be inscribed upon
our hearts as you have promised in
Jesus' name. Amen.
Amen.
Thank you for watching this video.
To subscribe to our channel, click here.
To get notifications, click on the bell.
To watch the next video,
click here.
Thank you and we'll see you again.